- So, why did former President
Trump's impeachment lawyers
all leave en masse?
And why can't he just just use Rudy?
Well, Rudy is a material
witness to this impeachment.
Jay Sekulow was too smart to ruin himself
over this particular impeachment,
though he was fine in
the last impeachment.
Well, it seems like the real problem
is that real lawyers don't like to lie,
either to courts or to Congress,
and they're worried
about their reputation.
Former President Trump is basically toxic
over the Capitol insurrection,
and it seems like Trump
wants to focus on this
as his primary defense,
that he was justified in making
all these crazy statements,
and these lawyers just aren't
going to put up with that,
whether it's for their reputation
or because it's completely illegal.
So, I know what you're thinking,
"Hopefully, President Trump
will represent himself, YOLO!"
So, subscribe, or I'll see you in court.